[Laughter]
abstract art has a place in this world
still hidden among us is a real artist
and it's your job to find out who it is
well competing three rounds of
challenges before we reveal the truth
can you figure it out I've been doing
the art all my life since I was a little
kid I knew that I wanted to be a painter
for the rest of my life so I've been
practicing and getting better since I
was in kindergarten I've always loved
art I grew up in like a little town so
there weren't that many artistic
programs so a lot of it was just work
with what you have and I would just
paint I was just paint in my room my my
walls were painted my parents couldn't
control it like I moved from the
canvases to the whole wall I've been
drawing and painting since before I
could remember even talking or walking
but as a young professional I've been
practicing art for 10 years I became
passionate about art from a very young
age I used to draw all over the walls my
desk any piece of paper I could find I
actually stained my mother's coffee
table with a bunch of permanent markers
all in pink because of course and I
decided to make it my profession you're
about to see me compete in these next
three challenges you're gonna find that
on the real artist here
[Music]
trying to find it I'm gonna try the head
first I'm gonna start with my eye
[Music]
mm-hmm eyebrows and I have some eyebrows
somewhere maybe a nose a mouth hair
[Music]
there Stosh my lips
hopefully this these are my lips I don't
we can get any farther from there like
maybe a body I don't know if it looks
like my beard but it felt like it an ear
these arms probably aren't even attached
honestly at this point
suppress and some hair over here not too
much anymore and I think it looks a
little bit like me but let's actually
open my eyes and see if I feel that okay
[Music]
you know what it's abstract oh I stand
by it that's not that bad I thought it
was gonna be a lot worse
is it an improvement my five heads gone
but now it appears that more it's just
move places and I think that abstract
art has a place in this world still
let's see which colors would you mix to
make this shade of purple and gay I
should know this I don't how to make
purple this shade is pretty bright the
brightest two colors nice okay which one
of these makes orange now you'd think
that this would be obvious but now I'm
not so sure I feel there are a lot of
pressure okay that one that was wrong Oh
which one of you makes green it's not
easy so this is like a really lime green
so this hot blue is speaking to me
I'm gonna get it wrong on Thai the
middle one okay good okay I'm back
okay which one of these makes pink if I
get this one wrong I'm in trouble this
pink is like a rose so not so orange I
think I think it's gonna be more red mmm
okay I'm gonna go with this one I'm just
gonna go with that's wrong as well oh no
[Laughter]
okay I'm an artiste so for this last
challenge that gave me all of these
shapes so I'm just gonna see what I can
make out of it I'm seeing a little bit
of a tree trunk right here this is a
building
this is a river that we're going to do
eyebrow situation a strong defined brow
is in 2020 trend alert eyebrows you've
got a lovely lovely man walking his dog
over here gonna be lots of water and
then there's little people there fishing
his father-son bonding
we're father/daughter you know I'm gonna
go ahead and some of you might say
Daniel I liked just the simple lines
before and you know what I say to that
me too but you know what we're going for
it we're going for full fantasy not the
most imaginative thing of in the world
but that's what I saw that's why they're
in in this little little birds there's a
little Hawks befall everything
everyone's there oh my god I heard that
I'm not surprised because you know I'm
very talented and what else should we do
for the finishing touch a beauty mark if
it's good enough for Marilyn it's good
enough for anybody right voila see a
resemblance
[Music]
well it looks like the end of the
competition so I guess it's time to come
clean
I am NOT a professional artist
sorry about it I'm actually a stand-up
comedian based in Los Angeles and I make
a living out of making fun of everything
but mostly myself alright guys well I'm
not the professional painter but I am a
practicing artist and designer whether
that be graphic design video editing
creative directing art is still a big
part of my life alright it wasn't me um
but I am an artist I do believe that I'm
an artist I I do a lot of things that
are artistic I'm a nail tech you know I
do paint you know it's just on a little
campus you know and I did paint my room
my parents you know they're still
dealing with that you know my room still
painted and crazy and took them forever
to remodel it after I moved out but yeah
it's not me I'm not a professional
artist did you guess correctly I'm the
real artist so as I said before I
started very very young I had my first
exhibition when I was 7 years old and
from then on I just kept exhibiting I
moved to London when I was 16 and I
started art up to a master's degree I've
done some shows in Europe in the US and
in Mexico where I'm originally from
I'm also a teacher an art center where I
teach anything from like young kids to
professional artists that I mentor and
and I'm also a freelance filmmaker